[Music]
and good evening welcome to our season
finale of face-off with derek england
it's fun it's a fast season and we can't
wait
for next season to already begin joining
me here is our
hockey expert derek england derek it's
hard to believe that the season is
almost
well it is over and it's almost gonna
training camp is gonna be right around
the corner
yeah it's uh you know if yes a month and
a half ago it's like dragging on then
and now it's it's done and
next season it feels like it's just
around the corner you know another
two months and uh guys are gonna be
skating getting ready for testing in
camp
as players are does the season go fast
or do you look at it and say wow it's
already over
uh it's it's kind of up and down the the
first part first
i don't know 30 games of the season
seems to fly by and then you hit that
january
february lull and then the last month
and a half it
flies by into playoffs all right well
the big news of course today was that
the nhl has announced
that las vegas will host the 2022 nhl
all-star game and festivities
probably anticipated great news for las
vegas yeah i think it's huge um
you know especially for the fans you
know it's uh it's a chance for them to
get
you know a little more intimate style
with
all the stars around the league you know
you get to see them all in one
one ring the the skills competition is a
lot of fun for those guys and
let's talk about the season now derek i
want to ask you if you had to give a
grade if you were the teacher and you
gave the season
uh with the knights of great what would
you give it and why i
i still got to go with an a
you know to make it to the final four is
uh is extremely hard
we've been very fortunate three three of
the four years we've been in
the final four teams so you know i know
people think they came up short and guys
on the team think they come up short but
uh just to make it this
this far in is still a great
accomplishment very impressive indeed
and what are your three impressions if
you had impressions to improve the team
what would they be well one i think you
just listen to pete it's the power play
they kind of got skunked there in the
last round and
playoffs it wasn't great so that's the
one key area
and then just maybe a little grit and
that net front presence
you know i thought coming down the
stretch maybe it's lacking a little bit
there
let's play word association now i'm
going to give you a name and you tell me
the first thing that pops into your head
when i when i give you this name
first off bill foley amazing
amazing yeah just all he does is uh it's
amazing
george mcphee intense kelly mccrimmon
also intense i i stay with him again so
intense yeah
uh marc-andre fleury uh fun
brayden mcnabb
ah jeez
i'm trying to think of the word i'm
coming up like right now
quietly aggressive maybe slightly
aggressive yeah and then i know a play a
former golden knight you're good friends
with and he was a fan favorite here a
lot of people liked him
when i say nate schmidt what comes to
mind
everything
obnoxious fun and obnoxious yeah i mean
he was a fan favorite people loved it
amazing yeah awesome guy
well derek it's been a lot of fun this
season until next season of course a fun
informative season we've we've had a
pleasure it's just been so much fun
having you here giving us that unique
perspective on the golden knights and
the season and
and different players hope you have a
fun summer and we'll see you back here
in the fall
sounds good thanks for having me there
he is all right